>> Greg: WHEN FACED WITH
CRITICISM, THE MEDIA SAYS IT’S
THEIR JOB TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> I THINK THESE BRIEFINGS COULD
BE BETTER DESIGNED, COULD COME
OUT AND SAY A FEW WORDS IN TERMS
OF WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING, NOT HAVE THESE P.R.
STUNTS LIKE MR. PILLOW COMING
OUT AND GIVING A PLUG FOR HIS
COMPANY.
>> IS OBVIOUSLY ABOVE MY PAY
GRADE BUT IT SEEMS CRAZY TO ME
THAT EVERYONE IS STILL THINKING
THEM WHEN YOU’VE GOT THE
MYPILLOW GUY GETTING UP THERE
TALKING ABOUT READING THE BIBLE.
>> Greg: IT WASN’T JUST TV,
NONESSENTIAL BOZOS WITH BLUE
CHECKMARKS ALSO TOOK TO TWITTER
TO MOCK MIKE LINDELL.
BUT WHILE THEY SNARK AWAY, HE
WAS CONVERTING HIS BUSINESS INTO
MAKING 50,000 MASKS A DAY SO
LAUGH ALL YOU WANT.
THE OBJECT OF YOUR RIDICULE WILL
SAVE LIVES.
HE IS AN AMERICAN SUCCESS STORY
BUT BECAUSE HE MENTIONS THE
BIBLE TOO MUCH, HE IS WORTHY OF
MEDIA SCORN BECAUSE THEY’RE SO
MUCH BETTER THAN HIM.
SO AS WE STRIVE TO UNITE AGAINST
ONE OF THE GREATEST FOES WE’VE
EVER FACED, YOU’VE GOT TO ASK
DOES THAT REALLY HELP?
AND DOES THIS HELP?
>> DO YOU THINK THERE IS BLOOD
ON THE PRESIDENT’S HANDS
CONSIDERING THE SLOW RESPONSE OR
IS THAT TOO HARSH CRITICISM?
>> LEAVING ASIDE THE ELECTION
ITSELF, WHOSE ECO-VIRUS, ORLANDO
NIGHTCLUB SHOOTING, THERE’S
GOING TO BE A LOT OF NEWS IN THE
NEXT NINE MONTHS.
>> CORONAVIRUS IS CLEARLY A
DISTANCE GOING TO IMPACT CHINA
AND WAYS IN OUR ECONOMY THEY WE
HAVEN’T CONTEMPLATED.
TO BACK WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE TO
DUMP THIS B.S.
HELPS NO ONE.
TIME TO WASH OUR HANDS OF THE
BLOOD ON OUR HANDS LINE.
THE MEDIA AND PRESS CAN FIND A
REAL QUESTION, ONE THAT SEEKS AN
ANSWER INSTEAD OF ATTENTION.
SO YOU HAD MENTIONED THIS BEFORE
AND THAT A BLOCK, WHAT’S YOUR
TAKE ON THE ATTACK ON POOR
MR. PILLOW MAN.
THE MEDIA SNOBS DON’T THINK MIKE
HAS THE CORPORATE PEDIGREE TO BE
AT THE ROSE GARDEN.
THE MEDIA SNOBS HOLD TECHNOLOGY
EXECUTIVES AND VERY HIGH REGARD,
BUT THEY LOOK DOWN ON
INDUSTRIALISTS, MANUFACTURERS,
PROCTER & GAMBLE, UNITED
TECHNOLOGY AND REALLY LOOKED OUT
ON PEOPLE THAT USE INFOMERCIALS
TO SEND THEIR PRODUCT LIKE MIKE.
WHAT REALLY SET THEM OFF FIRST
WAS SAYING READ THE BIBLE.
THEY DON’T UNDERSTAND MIKE AS A
RECOVERING ADDICT.
THAT’S AN AFFIRMATION FOR HIM.
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT
PEOPLE RECOVERING FROM ADDICTION
DO THAT.
AND IT’S IMPORTANT TO THEM.
THE OTHER THING TO UNDERSTAND IS
WHENEVER A CULTURE IS CHALLENGED
BY A WAR, A PANDEMIC, AND
ECONOMIC DEPRESSION, THE CULTURE
ALWAYS DIGS DEEPER INTO THEIR
FACE.
IT’S HAPPENED THROUGHOUT HISTORY
EVERY SINGLE TIME AND THE FACT
THE MEDIA DOESN’T HAVE THE
EMPATHY FOR THAT, THE BUSINESS
INTELLIGENCE, THE COMPASSION TO
UNDERSTAND THAT REALLY JUST
MAKES ME REALIZE HOW SHALLOW
THEY ARE.
ON CHUCK TODD AND NANCY, YOU CAN
EITHER BE WITH US OR YOU CAN BE
AGAINST US.
SOME PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
ARE TRYING TO HELP AND THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY WHO
ARE TRYING TO DIVIDE.
THE PRESIDENT, THE DEMOCRATS, NO
ONE HAS BEEN PERFECT.
THAT’S BEEN MUCH MORE CRITICAL
IN SAVING LIVES.
IN WE CAN PLAY THIS GAME ALL DAY
ABOUT WHO IS POSITIVE, WHO IS
NEGATIVE, AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
NANCY PELOSI JUST A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO WAS IN DOWNTOWN
SAN FRANCISCO TELLING EVERYBODY
TO GO TO CHINATOWN, GET IN THE
BIG CROWD, GO TO THE RESTAURANTS
AND SHOP.
HE WAS TELLING EVERYBODY ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT WHILE THIS VIRUS WAS
SPREADING.
CHUCK TODD MODERATED THE
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE
JUST A LITTLE WHILE AGO.
YOU KNOW HOW MANY QUESTIONS HE
ASKED ABOUT THE VIRUS?
ZERO.
WE CAN DO THIS ALL DAY LONG.
IT’S NOT IMPORTANT, BUT WHAT IS
IMPORTANT AS EVERYBODY NEEDS TO
GET ON THE SAME PAGE AND TO HELP
HELP.
>> Greg: I THOUGHT YOU WERE
GOING TO GO ON.
IT’S A WEIRD MEDIA HYPOCRISY
THAT IF A RELIGIOUS PERSON DOES
SOMETHING REALLY BAD, IF YOU
MENTION THE RELIGION, YOU’RE A
BIGOT.
BUT IF SOMEBODY WHO’S VERY
RELIGIOUS DOES SOMETHING GOOD,
YOU CAN MAKE FUN OF THEM
MERCILESSLY.
SO YOU MIGHT BE ISLAMOPHOBIC IF
YOU TALK ABOUT TERRORISM BUT YOU
CAN MAKE FUN OF MIKE LINDELL
BECAUSE HE MENTIONS THE BIBLE
AND PEOPLE WHO READ THE BIBLE
ARE A BUNCH OF IDIOTS ACCORDING
TO THE MEDIA.
>> Dagen: IF YOU DON’T MAKE
FUN OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO CITE
SCRIPTURE AS PART OF THEIR
RECOVERY AND THEIR LIFE AND
THEIR EFFORT, IF YOU DON’T MAKE
FUN OF THOSE PEOPLE, YOU’RE NOT
GETTING INVITED TO CHUCK TODD’S
COCKTAIL SOIREE THAT HE’S GOING
TO THROW FOR ALL THE LEFT-WING
LIBERAL BODIES WHEN ALL OF THIS
IS OVER.
THAT GOES TO THE POINT WE ARE A
NATION THAT ROUTES FOR RECOVERY
AND REDEMPTION.
WE ARE A NATION OF PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE IN SECOND CHANCES, SO I
THINK ALL OF THESE PEOPLE NEED
TO GO IN THERE MAN CAVE AND LOOK
IN THE MIRROR AND ASK
THEMSELVES, AND MY ROOTING FOR
CATASTROPHE, FOR A DESK, FOR
DYING, FOR SUFFERING BECAUSE IT
MIGHT BENEFIT MYSELF SOMEHOW AND
I MIGHT HAVE MORE POWER BECAUSE
I THINK THEY NEED A REAL HARD
CHECK AND A HARD LOOK IN THE
MIRROR AND ASK THEMSELVES AT THE
END OF THE DAY, DO I JUST NEED
TO SHUT UP?
>> Greg: YOU ARE A GOD-FEARING
MAN, YOU GO TO MASS EVERY
SUNDAY.
I AM NOT.
I AM AN AGNOSTIC.
I REFLECT PROBABLY MORE THE
MEDIA THAN YOU DO IN THAT SENSE.
DOES IT BOTHER YOU WHEN YOU SEE
THAT THEY KIND OF LOOK DOWN
THEIR NOSES AT SOMEBODY FOR
BEING FROM OPENLY TALKING ABOUT
GOD AND THE BIBLE?
>> Juan: AT SHERWOOD BECAUSE
THEY BE LOOKING DOWN AT ME.
BUT I DIDN’T TAKE IT THE WAY
THAT YOU DID READ I SAW IT AS
PEOPLE SAYING THAT MIKE LINDELL
STOOD UP THERE AND HE STARTED
MAKING POLITICAL STATEMENTS
ABOUT DIVINE INTERVENTION IN
NOVEMBER OF 2016 WHEN TRUMP WON,
SO WE TURNED INTO SOMETHING OF A
POLITICAL RALLY WHEN IT WAS
INTENDED TO BE A BRIEFING FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ON THE
CORONAVIRUS.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP EVEN
SAID I’M SURPRISED HE SAYS THAT,
SIGNALING TO ME THAT HE DIDN’T
SET IT UP.
DIDN’T SEEM APPROPRIATE I GUESS
TO THE PRESIDENT EITHER.
MY BIGGER POINT THOUGH IN REGARD
TO THE CHUCK TODD THING IS I
THINK THAT YOU’RE RIGHT IN THAT
WAS A DIVISIVE KIND OF
STATEMENT.
WASN’T ABOUT INSIDER
INFORMATION, IT WAS ABOUT
SETTING UP A FIGHT.
LET ME HOLD YOUR JACKET WHILE
YOU TO GO HEAD-TO-HEAD.
I DIDN’T THINK THAT WAS RIGHT.
BUT IF IT’S ABOUT THE QUESTION
OF MOBILIZATION RIGHT NOW,
AMERICA IS MOBILIZED FOR ACTION
IN DEALING WITH THIS VIRUS.
THAT’S THE RIGHT RESPONSE NOW,
WHY CAN’T YOU SAY THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN THE RIGHT RESPONSE
EARLIER IN THE RIGHT RESPONSE A
MONTH AGO?
SO IF THAT’S THE DIRECTION OF
THE JOURNALIST CHUCK TODD GOING
THERE, I WOULD SAY THAT’S
INFORMATIONAL AND LEGITIMATE AND
LET’S LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE AND
WHAT WE ARE DOING.
BUT SETTING UP A PHONY FIGHT AND
EVEN AS YOU HEARD FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN, HE SAID I
WOULDN’T SAY THAT.
THAT’S TOO HARSH.
THAT’S TOO FAR.
>> Greg: THE PROBLEM WITH THAT
QUESTION ABOUT QUESTIONING HOW
FAST ONE SHOULD DO SOMETHING CAN
BE APPLIED TO EVERY SINGLE GOOD
THING IN LIFE BECAUSE EVERY
SINGLE GOOD THING IN LIFE COULD
BE STARTED SOONER BUT THAT WILL
SAVE THAT.
I KEEP HEARING THE TRAIN.
IS THAT IN YOUR TOWN?
>> Dagen: CAN YOU HEAR IT?
>> Greg: I CAN HEAR THE TRAIN.
>> Dagen: I WAS WORRIED YOU
WOULD THINK IT WAS MY STOMACH.
>> Greg: I CAN RECOGNIZE THAT
NEW JERSEY TRAIN ANYWHERE
BECAUSE I’VE BEEN THERE, I KNOW
THE TRAIN.
IT’S YOUR BACKYARD.
>> Dagen: IT CAME YESTERDAY
TOO.
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS PRESS
SECRETARY, THERE WAS ONE NETWORK
NEWS REPORTER, NOT GOING TO NAME
HIM, AND I REMEMBER ONE TIME
WHERE THE PRESIDENT WAS GIVING A
SPEECH AND AT THE END OF THE
SPEECH, THE PRESIDENT SAID MAY
GOD BLESS YOU, MAY GOD BLESS
AMERICA.
WHEN THIS REPORTER SLAMMED HIS
HANDS ON THE TABLE AND SAID I
CAN’T STAND IT.
I WAS JUST SHOCKED.
THEN I REALIZED, THEY WOULD MAKE
FUN OF GEORGE W. BUSH FOR BEING
A FAITHFUL PERSON ALL THE TIME.
IT’S A REAL CLICHE PARADIGM IT
SORT OF LIKE WHEN SOMEBODY SAYS
WHAT GRADE WOULD YOU GIVE
YOURSELF FOR THE CORONAVIRUS?
THOSE QUESTIONS TO ME ARE SO
LAZY.
BUT ALSO, LET’S SAY SOMETHING
NICE ABOUT JOE BIDEN WHO DIDN’T
TAKE THE BAIT AND WHO SAID NO, I
THINK THAT’S A LITTLE TOO HARSH.
THAT WAS VERY STATESMANLIKE AND
HE SHOULD GET SOME CREDIT FOR
THAT.
>> Greg: THE ONLY PERSON YOU
COULD ASK IF YOU HAVE BLOOD ON
YOUR HANDS AS O.J. SIMPSON,
RIGHT?
NOT TO HIS FACE AND IF HE IS
HOLDING A KNIFE, RUN.
>> Dana: LET ME ASK YOU, DO
YOU THINK ANY OF THESE REPORTERS
WOULD ASK PRESIDENT XI THAT SAME
QUESTION?
>> Greg: PROBABLY NOT.
THAT IS A GOOD QUESTION.
I CAN’T READ MINDS, BUT I THINK
IT’S ONE OF THOSE FALLBACK
QUESTIONS THAT WE SHOULD JUST
GET RID OF IT.
>> Dana: A BAD DENIGRATING
QUESTION COME OUT.
>> Jesse: THIS IS MEET THE
PRESS.
I DON’T THINK CHUCK HAS THE
CHOPS TO HOST THAT SHOW.
REGARDLESS, THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE WILL
BRIEF VERY SOON AND WE WILL WAIT
FOR THAT.
PEOPLE WHO DON’T PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING COULD END UP BEHIND
BARS.
THE MAYOR OF WASHINGTON, D.C.,
THREATENING 90 DAYS IN JAIL FOR
RESIDENTS WHO VIOLATE OR STAY
ORDER.
A THEY COULD ALSO BE FACING A
HEFTY $5,000 FINE.
THE MAYOR NOW BACKTRACKING A
LITTLE BIT SAYS HE WOULD ENFORCE
THAT ORDER WITH A HEAVY HAND.
AND TAKE A LOOK AT AT THIS SCENE
COMING OUT OF L.A.
A HUGE LIGHT OF POLICE OFFICERS
WITH A BIRTHDAY PARTY FOR A
1-YEAR-OLD.
AROUND 40 PEOPLE ATTENDED.
NO ONE WAS ARRESTED BUT THEY
SENT A STAY-AT-HOME ORDER.
AT ONE, THESE GOVERNORS WERE
THESE LOCAL OFFICIALS HAVE A LOT
OF POWER IN A TIME LIKE THIS.
SOME ARE USING IT SMARTLY.
SOME ARE USING IT A LITTLE
HEAVY-HANDED, BUT IT’S ALL ON
THEM.
HOW DO YOU THINK IT’S SHAKING
OUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY?
>> Juan: THIS IS MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AS I’M IN D.C. SO
LAST NIGHT WHEN I WENT FOR A
WALK WITH MY WIFE, I WENT DOWN
TO THE LOCAL RECREATION CENTER
AND THERE WAS A GUARD STANDING
BY THE TENNIS COURTS AND THE
BASKETBALL COURTS AND THE
SWIMMING ARENA THERE.
IF YOU CAN’T PLAY TENNIS, CAN’T
GET ON THE BASKETBALL COURT,
I’VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS.
BUT WHAT’S GOOD ABOUT THIS IS
THERE’S COORDINATION.
SO WE HAVE RALPH NORTHAM WHO WAS
THE GOVERNOR NEIGHBORING
VIRGINIA AND ENABLING MARYLAND
ALL ISSUING STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS.
LOCKED IT BACK A LITTLE BIT AND
SAID NOT TRYING TO PUT PEOPLE IN
JAIL, BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY GET THE MESSAGE THAT RIGHT
NOW SOCIAL DISTANCING IS HELPING